to talk with someone who has additional
insight into the royal family so we're
joined now by john quelch he is the dean
of uh the business school university of
miami but he also received what's called
a cbe from the queen it is the highest
award that can be given as the commander
of the royal order of the british empire
john thanks so much for joining us today
uh thank you very much
this is um for a lot of people
not necessarily a surprise but it is
turning the page into a new era do you
imagine or understand what the mood is
like overseas right now
uh so
obviously this event was anticipated but
it's no less sad for for being
anticipated
there is going to be an outpouring of
grief not only in the united kingdom but
around the world
because the queen was the head of state
for 15 nations
she was the head of the commonwealth of
nations 54 nations and i think perhaps
alongside the pope was perhaps the most
recognized a political public figure on
the world stage and so it's a very big
pair of shoes to fill
for king charles certainly so a reign of
some 70 years spanning many decades so i
know it's impossible to pinpoint one
thing but what do you think her legacy
will be
well
as a as a business school professor
for a moment i'm going to say
that
she was the consummate quiet leader
someone who
provided the glue that held together not
only her own
family but held together
the british people and held together a
community of nations as well
so
it's that
leadership capacity and how many of us
have ever met someone who held the same
leadership role for 70 years that
leadership capacity the resilience along
with the compassion and sense of
humanity uh that will i think be the
enduring legacy apart from of course her
own family uh the nate the current king
and the next king and beyond that
so is king charles officially king at
this moment
so he has to be uh
crowned uh king
but in lieu of queen elizabeth
he is the
head of state
at this point so there will of course be
a coronation where he is officially
crowned king and what can we expect to
see in the coming days and weeks is
there an official period of mourning
will she lie in state or anything along
those lines
um
i think that that's really a question
mark at this point but there is no doubt
that she will receive the absolute
highest possible um
recognition in terms of uh everything
that is within the protocol of the
british monarchy to bestow and i would
expect to see a very very significant
period of
if not official morning unofficial
morning because
this is a lady who
bore
a huge level of importance
for many millions of people not only in
the uk but around the world
john quilts really appreciate your
insight and your time today thanks for
joining us
thank you
queen elizabeth ii
britain's longest reigning monarch died
today at the age of 96 she spent an
unprecedented 70 years on the throne